et on passe maintenant à informations
importantes sur le casting de danse avec
les stars
à croire qu'ils ne savent plus quoi
faire pour cette tournée démission parce
que on a évoqué le nom de mamoudou
gassama jeune homme qui est devenu
célèbre ou savez en sauvant sept enfants
qu'il a grandi comme ça tu es le spider
man l'immeuble et il aurait été
pressenti pour faire cette émission
alors évidemment ça a scandalisé les
gens sur twitter qui ont tu t'es plein
de choses dont ils sont en train de
faire de la mode ou une bête de foire
qu'est ce que vous en pensez mais c'est
sûr que c'est vrai la mort alors aidé à
arrêter c'est vrai déjà rata pas vérifié
mais non je m'étais fait tu dises que
mes sûr que non c'est pas vrai accord
donc moi j'aurais tendance à les croire
alors moi j'ai vérifié c'est faux eh oui
donc en fait on a contacté à la
rédaction l'entourage de mamoudou
gassama et cet entourage dément
formellement toute proche et nous dit
que s'il y a une approche à venir
mahmoud n'ira jamais donc en fait d'als
à voulu exploiter commercialement le
geste d'un héros je trouve ça scandaleux
d'où ça sort d'où l'on sépare à vous
sauter d'une hypothèse qui sorbonne ses
ouailles essayons sa vive à la
conclusion ce sont des salopards ils ont
voulu j'ai pas dis salopards jean-pierre
ça va partir en lui mais qu'il verra
jeudi
[Musique]
il suffisait qu'on en était presque en
vacances qui vont pas mettre dans ses
pas choqué c'est quoi des crois pas
moi j'ai choqué et j'y crois à vous y
croyez oui tu crois quoi
j'y crois que c'est je pense comme
gilles qu'il n'ya pas de fumée sans feu
de 6 à affûter sa fin est marquée par
l'ingérence et les toits arrêté avec
intérêt l'idée est pas parce que j
quelque chose que forcément ça c'est lié
à la téléralité faut pas abuser non plus
non parce que j'ai un cerveau succès
c'est réfléchi mais je sais aussi
assumer ce que je pense et je pense que
c'est un buzz alors est ce que vous
connaissez les noms également qui ont
été évoqués alors ça j'y crois ou alors
voulez vous je vous dise alors dites-moi
les accès wi relais vous je vous dis
alors je vais vous dire j'ai appelé son
producteur producteurs de pamela
anderson il m'a dit qu'ils n'ont même
pas reçu une demande de la production
donc c'est faux le magazine
oui me résigner compris
non non il me l'aurait dit d'eux qu'ils
ont pu dire pas de fumée sans feu le
séparer mais oui c'est pas bien sûr pour
moi et ma vie personnelle à sa place
dans danse avec bien vous mais ça
résiste pas à l'analyse
pardon mais voilà la lige sa demande
d'être régulière des semaines durant
il y en a bien qui ils vont dans les
musées c'est une américaine tina à la
tournée des séries lui a enlevé à la
coupe là du matin mais son antre
s'occuper avoir une astreinte tels que
danse avec les stars et baidu si je n'y
crois pas un car deux ans et demi né en
astreinte d'emploi du temps et pendant
les chaleurs signé un contrat de dix ans
je sortirai la deuxième ou troisième
semaine c'est impossible et sinon c'est
largement discutés dans le combat là
s'est demandée une appellation c'est un
chat passe à 600 remontrer niveau de
l'émission lord